President Trump is threatening to impose
new sanctions on Venezuela if the
government rewrites its constitution
critics say president Nicolas Maduro
wants to tighten his grip on power and
silence protesters amid an economic
collapse sanctions could include a ban
on imports of Venezuelan oil that could
mean rising gas prices for Americans
Venezuela has yet to allow CBS News to
enter the country Manuel Bojorquez is on
its border with Colombia where the
crisis is spilling over men well good
morning good morning this is the bridge
that connects the two countries and
though it's always been a busy border
crossing the number of Venezuelans
walking this way into Colombia only
increases as the violence and
instability in their country intensifies
the luggage coming through makes this
look like an airport but it's the bridge
that spans the border between Venezuela
and cúcuta Colombia thousands of
Venezuelans cross daily in search of
food medicine and work some return home
but Marcos Gonzalez says he can't it's
very difficult
his wife and son are coming with him so
he had a heart surgery there's no
medicine she says he has autism too and
needs medication on the other side of
the border protesters and Venezuelan
Armed Forces clash almost daily they are
fighting over the socialist government's
policies which could explain for the
economic collapse americano president
Nicolas Maduro yesterday fired back at
us attempts to intervene you blame the
president and his policies like goodbye
el presidente says - yes it's medoras
fault says seventeen-year-old Rosa
Gonzalez a Venezuelan who left her
country to give birth in Colombia you
just can't have a baby there now she
says you can't get medicine the
hospitals are contaminated you feel like
there's no other option oh yeah no I
don't know if Venezuela will be able to
recover from this she said Marco's
Gonzales and his family hoped the
country will and hate to leave home
a lot of pain
for long afternoons don't seem like this
is real life this week Colombia's
president traveled to Cuba then as well
as Ally hoping to find a diplomatic
solution but right now neither side
seems willing to back down the
opposition says it will start forming an
alternate government today Nora right
incredible reporting there Manuel
Bojorquez near the Venezuelan border
thank you